after many years of diving into many
professional development programs my
interest in professional education has
been really about staying relevant if
you're not constantly learning if you're
not challenging your thinking or looking
at things in a different way you will
too become irrelevant and this program
at stanford the innovation
entrepreneurship program
teaches you how to think differently
so before i attended the program at
stanford innovation was still a very
complex and intimidating concept
but the program at stanford simplified
it and the faculty made sense of it for
me and they really wrapped innovation
entrepreneurship and design thinking all
together
so now that i've completed two programs
at stanford i can say that stanford has
never let me down
after each program i walk away with the
feeling that my expectations were
exceeded
and that the return on the investment
was greater than i could ever imagine
stanford actually makes it really easy
for you to learn at your own pace
choose your hours choose the courses
that really interest you and that you
want to focus in and they provide a
powerful learning platform that is
engaging and exciting to learn from
stanford provides the best program out
there i would highly recommend it it
will change your life